what do you think is the influence Rogan
and musk have in flipping votes so
just two three four years ago
Joe Rogan endorsed Bernie Sanders yeah
okay whatever the timeline was Elon Musk
voted for Joe Biden just three years ago
now both of them are saying to save the
country you have to vote Republican and
not even that Joe went as far as saying
I would vote for Trump okay I would vote
for Trump let me read the story and then
you guys can give me your number and
folks if you're listening to this I want
you to put your answer as well some of
you guys watch the podcast so you know
what they said but I want to hear your
answer
um
I would vote for Joe I would vote for
Donald Trump you're all going to post
Joe Biden's cabin to run the world's the
most powerful country I would vote for
Trump before I would vote for Biden the
thing with bideness he's gone you know
he's gone you're going to be relying on
his cabinet and I knew his cabinet would
be a sideshow of diversity you can't
have those kinds of people running a Ben
and Jerry's you
you kind of people running in effing the
muffin most powerful country in the
world has ever known it's nuts said Joe
Rogan on his podcast okay so now show
the number one podcast in the world Elon
Musk runs Twitter richest man in America
most powerful guy in America the way he
is doing what he's doing with social
media and Technology
if they say vote Republican with elon's
140 million followers Joe Rogan's
podcast how many votes can they flip
how many votes can they flip out of how
many so all you have to do is you have
to say you know a hundred thousand of
their votes that they would follow their
lead to go a you know a Libertarian like
Joe Joe Jorgensen or a Democrat to
announcing I'm gonna vote for Trump
because Joe Rogan said vote for Trump
because Elon Musk said a vote for Trump
if these guys smarter than me are saying
something like this I should consider it
how many things will flip I'm gonna go
to you first I mean I think like
percentage-wise no number number because
because remember Trump lost 75 to 81
million
okay Trump lost 75 to 81 am I saying it
correctly 71 75 to 81 million yeah so
how many that will flip just because of
Joe Rogan and Elon Musk wow
15 10 to 15 million
what is that bad attitude of people
going you know what Joe Rogan's telling
let me see what's happening
you asked the number of votes last and
what I had done is of the 12 Indies I
think Rogan can move
two of those percentage points and I
think Elon can move four that's that's a
big number so I'm saying
no no I'm saying if you give each of
them two and two of the 12 Indies in the
middle I think Rogan and Elon if they're
on the same side they'd move two each I
think you could move forward to how many
million go to 2020 total independent
voters
total independent voters in 2020
election hey you take the total voters
and do 40 43 and 43 and everybody else
total election so how many people voted
it was like 156 yeah is that correct
150 75 and 81. so 75 and 81 is is uh
yeah 150
156. so the the middle was probably 20
million right there in the middle 15 and
half of 15 is seven so yeah
you're talking about Rogan and Elon
going hey guys listen do not vote
Democrat 100 they're going to be going
aggressively
at once they go over and over and over
they are super concerned about what's
going to be happening these guys will be
pushing this you know a a I'm I wouldn't
be surprised if DeSantis is on Rogan's
podcast in the next three to six months
I wouldn't be surprised if possibly
Trump meets with musk and they have a
meeting and I wouldn't be surprised if
some of those think those things happen
after they know who's on the right so if
it's the santis DeSantis has got to be
on Rogan's podcast if they haven't
already had the conversation that is a
must but here's the point Tom two to
four percent
think about that number two to four
percent okay that's a real number it's
not 15 million two to four percent ends
up becoming what 10 15 million so you're
saying really the two to four percent
of the 12 is what you're saying so now
two to four percent of the 54 points of
those 14 points two to four points of
those 14 points correct so two to four
points of the let's just use the number
three okay three of fourteen
uh uh uh so let's let's let's do 156.
what's 156 times 14 14 well every every
one percent is 1.56 so so what is that
times 14.
that's what I'm saying so if we do 21
22. five six times
21 is what you're doing yeah like 21
people that are honestly in the middle
and that's your swing that we've all
know about which is 14 or 13 percent
right around there okay let's just say
13 yeah so that's 20 million okay 20
million you got 2 is 4 million that's
not enough
but three percent it's game over
okay you know what clay Travis and Buck
Sexton said he said only a hundred
thousand no he said one million no no
they said a hundred thousand can you rob
do you remember if it was a hundred
thousand or one million I don't remember
can you while we're doing this is there
a way you can find to see what they said
well see if you can I remember them
saying a hundred thousand let me give
you a little different perspective
the uh
the what do they call the general
population or when you win the um
general election when you win the uh
population what is it what is it called
not when you win the electoral college
popular vote there you go that's the
word I'm looking for yeah that to me is
irrelevant it's irrelevant because
you're not going to swing 5 million
voters or 10 million voters even 2
million voters you need to swing a
hundred thousand voters in Wisconsin
finally 11 000 votes in Georgia we all
know what happened there okay find me 20
000 votes in Wisconsin find me ten
thousand votes in Pennsylvania
did they say that okay so that's
essentially what it comes down to
whatever the swing states are we all
know that it's 51.49 it's
50.6 to
49.4 it's so close it's so razor thin
that you don't need to swing Millions
either side by the way you need there's
a you need these swing States these
swing cities these districts that can go
either way that's who you need to flip
and by the way we saw in Florida and the
gubernatorial election what happens when
the independence break 72 percent
the independence broke 72 for DeSantis
and you go take a look at the map
everything was read except Broward and
the small County on the south side of
Orlando correct correct and it's the
same thing that happened in 2016 the
those same Independence broke for Trump
because Hillary wasn't campaigning in
the blue States or in the blue wall and
the same thing happened in 2020 when all
those same voters broke for Biden so the
independence of where it's at we all
know that preaching to the choir and
losing Independence the independent the
true Independence
follow what Rogan and musk have to say
the true Independence follower the
Libertarians and The Independents follow
what Rogan and musk have to say fully
agree with that so absolutely agree so
to me when clay Travis and Buck Sexton
said a hundred thousand I'm like
yeah I don't know I think it's a bigger
number than that Tom if it's three
percent I don't think it's three percent
but I don't think it's a hundred
thousand but if those two
go and they supported the way they do
I I don't know I mean they could change
the time oh my God here's what I was
considering you wonder what I was
considering there what I was considering
was I remember what happened with Rush
Limbaugh and Newt Gingrich I remember
what happened and remember remember
that's that wave that came up and and
bit and bit Clinton really hard that was
that was like Rush demonstrating the
power you know of the medium of the time
now I look at it and I see what happened
with the Tea Party and so Pat it takes a
few voices but if the voices are a wave
it's not just Rogan it's Rogan's
influence base and it's the people that
are in that influence base that are
influencing others as well because right
yeah see I doubt the GOP would have won
the house in 94 without Rush Limbaugh
and that was what was Gingrich what he
called that contract with America was
that what it's called I think it was his
new thing anyway regardless of what it
was called the point was there was a
spark that pushed this thing over fast
and the same thing happened with tea
party so when things get tough and
there's a real Stark Choice America
voters can be moved what a point you
just made listen to this without rush I
doubt if we would have won the control
of his house in 1994 because he
clarified the issues Gingrich explained
he gave our candidates arguments to run
on he created a huge number of people
his impact was more than the 20 million
listeners a week it was all the people
they would go talk to wow my guess is
that the ripple effect of Rush was more
than 80 to 90 exactly that's exactly
what I'm saying with Rogan and musk
that's exactly what I think this is
going to be bigger I think this is going
to be if if Trump or the sentence can
win those two guys which descent is
they've both won over I mean he's won
both of them over you know both of them
their team the sentence is where they
are obviously musk doesn't want somebody
older than 70 his number was 69 even
younger than that so so
69 is more because anything to be less
than 70 anyways okay so we'll see I
think it's going to be a bigger number I
think I fully see that part where you're
training the trainers to go out there
and talk like we're having a meeting in
two weeks in Dallas 25 3000 people are
going to show up it's called train the
trainers that meaning when they leave it
turns into 50 to 100 000 insurance
policies we didn't sell any policies
that way we trained the trainers to go
and find them now we have 350 nearly 400
000 policies we've written in the last
13 years right so that is the effect of
what they leave and what they do okay
yeah this is really fast but it's kind
of weird that you we wouldn't need those
people in the middle need uh that
influence from uh musk or Rogan when
can't you can't they just open their
eyes and see what's happening in like
how horrible this Administration did but
but think about how how much people go
and say I need a Oprah Winfrey
endorsement but actually think about how
Oprah Winfrey endorsed fetterman yeah
here's how she endorsed them she says
look I know Oz is somebody that's worked
with me for many years and I know
everybody's expecting me to support us
but I'm supporting fetterman I think
he's a good guy I think he's this versus
the difference between the way she
endorses and rush or Elan or Rogan
endorses says the following listen I
have a heart look at Rogue what did
Rogan say Rogan said what how did Rogan
explain why he would vote for uh uh
Trump said the cabinet he said he said I
would vote for this because
you're gonna be relying on his cabinet
and I know his cabinet would be a
sideshow of diversity you can't have
those kinds of people running a Ben and
Jerry's you certainly can have those
kinds of people running a country the
most powerful country in the world so
that is an issue he's given to say it
was so much about diversity that you
didn't pick the best leaders for the job
right so the average person listens to
it and says that can't that's kind of
right he just shows diversity you can
have that so the way Oprah does it is
yes I support it's great versus the way
these guys are going to do this it's
going to be issue driven if it's issue
driven
about 80 to 90 million so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]